- [Narrator] This 165,000
square foot warehouse
is piled high
with liquidated goods, including
the never-ending stream
of things we've all been returning.
(boxes clattering)
Liquidation company Quicklotz
estimates that about 30%
of the products it receives
are clearly used returns.
- A little charger, watch,
this is like a very expensive Swiss watch.
Of course, underwear.
- [Narrator] Customer
returns are skyrocketing,
filling landfills and warehouses
like this one to the brim.
- A pallet like this we estimate to be
about 20, $30,000 in retail value.
- [Narrator] So how did it all get here?
And how are retailers feeling the impact
of an increasing number of unwanted goods.
When that pair of pants you bought online
doesn't fit quite right,
the solution is easy.
Return it and get a refund.
But after you mail them back,
where those pants end up
is a bit more complicated.
- The best of all possible answers
is that the good gets repackaged
and goes back on the shelf.
So it's ready for sale as a new item.
- [Narrator] But getting there is costly.
Reverse logistics company Optoro estimates
that on average it costs
66% of the price of an item
to process its return.
For example, if those pants
you returned were $50,
it would cost the retailer
$33 to take them back.
So many returns travel
through a complicated web
of warehouses, secondary
resellers, and landfills.
First up is a returns processing center
where the item gets inspected for damage.
Every company has a
different set of standards
for what can be repackaged and sold again,
(cardboard clattering)
and plenty of things don't meet them.
Optoro says that many
retailers throw away over 1/4
of returned goods in 2019.
The amount of returns and excess inventory
that retailers send to landfills
has more than doubled since 2016
from 4 billion pounds
to 9.6 billion pounds.
But everything else is harder to track.
The rest of the unwanted goods filter
through a secondary resale market,
including retailer outlets
and online auctions.
One path leads to liquidation
companies like Quicklotz.
- Retailers, their business is to retail.
Their business is not to
deal with rejected inventory.
They figure out
how to just streamline the
process by liquidating.
(truck beeping)
- Companies like Nordstrom, Target
and Best Buy send products
by the truck full.
Those trucks are filled with pallets
of both customer returns
and excess inventory
or items that never
sold in the first place.
- Everything comes bundled
together as liquidation,
and a lot of times, even
merchandise that are brand new.
They could have been returns
but they're hard to identify
because they got returned
with tags in brand new condition.
- [Narrator] The company
sells pallets wholesale
but it also sorts their items
by category and condition.
Its clients are other resellers,
from people listing on
marketplaces like eBay
or Poshmark to mom and pop discount stores
to flea market stands,
and now companies are dealing
with even more returns.
According to the National
Retail Federation,
customer returns across the
retail industry are growing.
As e-commerce sales explode,
online returns do too.
They've more than doubled
in the past few years
from 9.6% in 2019 to 20.8% in 2021.
- So when we shop at a
store, we see, feel, smell.
We know what we're getting.
When we shop online, we
don't have that sensation
and so we end up buying more items
so that we can see,
feel, smell, touch them.
(taping whooshing)
- [Narrator] Retailers
themselves have made it easier
with long return windows
and free shipping.
- Those policies that especially
Amazon created years ago
has increased that
convenience to the customer.
And because one retailer started,
everybody has to follow suit.
- [Narrator] Amling says retailers
would rather eat the cost
of returns than disappoint customers,
but at the end of the day,
returns still affect consumers.
- Those costs go into the price
that they charge for items
and ultimately that cost is born by us.
(forklift rumbling)
- [Narrator] For retailers
overwhelmed with returned goods,
offloading them to
liquidators can be a relief.
- [Alan] It's a painful process
and they just want to get rid of it.
They just want someone else to do it.
- [Narrator] And it can be
a way to recoup some loss.
Amling says if retailers think
that those goods will end up
in a landfill, selling them
to liquidators instead can
be an appealing choice.
Still returns eat into the bottom line.
- Retailers in a high-margin
business and a large part
of that are all of the costs that go
in to things like returns.
That is actively cutting into the margins
that retailers make.
- [Narrator] But it's tricky
to track the actual cost.
- The responsibility is
diffused among different groups
within the organization.
Too many companies are
not measuring the cost
that they're spending
on reverse logistics.
- [Narrator] As returns increase,
some retailers are changing their policies
but it's not widespread.
- Companies that are selling
goods that can be found
on other websites are gonna
find it much more difficult
because if I can find the
same product somewhere else
and it's free returns,
that's where I'm going.
- [Narrator] But despite
making small shifts,
Amling says retailers
aren't prioritizing dealing
with returned items.
- Right now, consumers have no idea
what happens to a return once they,
let's say drop it off at a UPS store.
Once that becomes
transparent, they will change.
(pensive music)
(packaging rattling)